lamborghini oh my goodness
who is this when you're a property
investor you sometimes need to just get
in the car
and go view the houses yourself you see
often the estate agent
they'll paint half the story you see and
i mean i've just viewed this
pub right here and this could be a
potential conversion
so the estate agent showed me you know
the agents are saying look if you turn
this into apartments
there's an apartment a quarter of a mile
away that sold for one two five
you know you do this really high end you
could turn that little pub into four
apartments
you get like a gdv on that and about 500
000 pounds i'm thinking maybe
the pub is like 150. could there be
profit to be made in there maybe
we just look round it now we're not too
sure are we
we're not too sure you need to actually
see this is what i saw this is what the
agent showed me
the pub looks nice you've got like a a
mcdonald's right there
mcdonald's you're in between the two
football clubs in liverpool popping
it's buzzing but here's the thing
there's no parking around here anywhere
okay i like to drive like
five minutes away to park and yes
there's mcdonald's and stuff but then if
you look slightly this side
this is what you couldn't see on the
picture there you go you couldn't see it
on the picture that's
that's rough hey what's happening yeah
yeah yeah
there we go you know that that that's
rough right there
and that's rough right there but all
these close down all these closed down
shops and stuff
and i just i just think you're not gonna
get one two five for those apartments
you're probably gonna be
you're probably gonna be looking to get
75. you'll be lucky to get a seventy
you'll be looking to get 75
65. so the thing is when you do when
you're doing these kind of calculations
there's three costs
i'm gonna keep saying this until people
start doing it there's three costs
there's the purchase price yeah you buy
that pub for 150.
then there's the gross development value
how much is it going to be done
once it's all done up what's the gross
development value and then
there's the the refurb cost the refurb
cost is going to be massive all kinds of
issues inside
gross development value don't just look
at the best case scenario
you know you can look at the best case
scenario and find something a quarter of
a mile away
a little apartment a quarter of a mile
away that's selling for one two five
but that was a quarter of a mile away
and this is here
and that was selling for one two five
but that wasn't
an ugly looking pub with nasty ass shops
next door
you gotta be negative man you gotta be a
pessimist in
in property be an optimist about
yourself be positive about yourself
but be be a pessimist and be negative
about the figures
and about everything else you know
that's what that that's really really
important
also get good people around you see when
i'm viewing these types of sites
i get a good idea about what's happening
myself but you know you need a cost
manager someone that's going to actually
tell you how much things are going to
cost
you only need to be wrong on a few
figures you need to be if you um
underestimate the cost of the refurb
just a little bit just by 10
but then you over estimate the cost of
the end value the gross development
value just a little bit
just by 10 suddenly killed your profit
i'm not giving up though man i'm not
giving up i just come to a different
neck of the woods i'm just outside
manchester i wish you could actually
hear me though
what is it with these noisy people in
these noisy cars
what is this this big ass lamborghini
oh my goodness who is this it's the one
and only
oh this is liv [ __ ] world champion
world champion uh did you want to go
view some houses together
absolutely let's make a wicked
development let's see if we can have
some better look just outside manchester
let's see what we can do let's go let's
go let's go i've got my whole crew on
with right now with ben
and with the amazing james and the
mathematician
the mathematician you've been has it
been a good day yeah it's been really
good i feel like i've learned a lot
you're amazing to be around and i'm
excited we're gonna do big things
unfortunately i can't show you inside
the next property in case you steal it
but it was amazing
this is better i'm now getting excited
i'm now getting excited
honestly i was getting a little bit
nervous about today
now i'm getting very excited the exact
opposite things just happened from what
happened before
before i was really excited about the
pub and the pub turned out how was it
live
terrible however we're just outside
manchester now live's pulled me just
outside manchester
we've just seen a property by mistake
how good was it it
is incredible it's exciting it looks
good doesn't it it's it's we
we we've we're thinking that except
about about 200 grand
yeah and um the gross development value
is 1.5 million 1.5 million pounds
it needs around about eight nine hundred
thousand pounds spending on it we've
even had a cost manager come and look at
it and here's the crazy thing here's the
crazy thing
we did not intend on finding that
property that was just like
oh we saw a piece of land we spoke to an
agent the agent pulled us to it
and i think relationships are better
than deals if you've got good
relationships if you can get in with
agents with investors with developers
with mathematicians with football
freestylers
deal's just it's been hard work with liv
though because she keeps getting stopped
all the time in the street and
people are asking for autographs i don't
even know autographs
you're recognized just as much yeah no
autographs you know what though
i keep thinking people stopping me and
i'm like oh yeah and then they're like
who the hell are you i wanted to
live but uh now honestly it's been a
great day and biggest lessons what do
you say the biggest lessons are
today i've gotta go with your quote go
on i forgot
it must have been good formulas not
feelings formulas not feelings that's
great so formulas not feelings
a good relationship is always better
than a good deal also get out view the
houses you cannot become successful in
property
by sat in front of an excel spreadsheet
i know your spreadsheets are good
they are good but they don't make you
rich what makes you wealthy is actually
going out viewing the houses oh hello hi
and we've got an
awesome look at this whoa
look at this says lamborghini leads
should say samuel leaps
bad bad bad
i like these cars i'm jealous i'm bored
i'm bored of that range rover now i'm
bored of that i'm bored of that range
rover now
okay you win i don't know about that i
don't know about that
thanks so much you need to follow us on
youtube yeah okay
so anyway i hope you guys enjoyed this
video smash subscribe you can subscribe
right over liv's face
it's right there right there if you want
to see more videos then you can check
them out right here
and i'll look forward to seeing you next
time i'll keep you posted watch this
space things are going to blow up
boom